hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you can't yell I
can't yell I am in Cologne Germany and
it is it is 149 whoops sorry 149 in the
[ __ ] morning and I'm [ __ ] wide
awake I'm still on [ __ ] la time what
time is it back there 9:00 our different
saints two o'clock it's about what 9:30
in the morning I don't what the [ __ ] it
is it's about 4:30 4 or 5 o'clock or
some [ __ ] anyways how are you how you
doing I made it over here the flight was
a [ __ ] joke I literally watched like
I watched one full movie alright it was
i watched dr. Strangelove one of my
favorite movies of all time and favorite
director Stanley Kubrick and Peter
Sellers everybody that movies [ __ ]
brilliant I watched that and then I
watched a half-hour of Good Will Hunting
I was like I am NOT literally not seen
this movie since I saw it in the movie
theaters I've seen bits and pieces
because it's on but I never just sat
down to watch it for those who've never
seen it he's wicked she's mad he cleans
the floors but he's wicked smaht so a
little bit of that and was crazy because
that movie doesn't seem that old to me I
was like wow man that [ __ ] movie is
21 years old and when I was just seeing
just a shot of the skyline of Boston how
much it's changed since then and how
much it's gentrified and gentrifying as
Boston is that the white people became
even whiter for most of those most of
those areas and then I watched the
beginning of Papillon the original was
Steve McQueen and Dustin Hoffman and
then I fell asleep and just [ __ ] woke
up in Germany
not that bad man was not that bad a
fight but here was the problem I landed
in Munich and had a connecting flight to
Cologne and they gave me a [ __ ]
one-hour window to catch it an 11 hour
flight and you're gonna give me a
one-hour window I was like before I even
get on the plane I'm like there's no
[ __ ] way I'm gonna make that thing so
much [ __ ] just a con tear of a headwind
for 11 hours and I'm gonna miss it and I
missed it I have [ __ ] sit there in
Munich get the goddamn Airport for like
[ __ ] three hours waiting for the last
little Southwest flight I had to take
was like an hour flight up to Cologne
wasn't that bad though but I mean I was
cracking me up lose make making me think
about the way they played football now
where before halftime you score a
touchdown you down by a point and rather
than going for the extra point they do
dumb [ __ ] like they go for a two-point
conversion and then they don't get it
rather than being tied up they're down
by one in the end you know there's some
hunting thing you know you're down by
four points instead of three now you get
a score a touchdown that was the travel
version of that so anyways I got to tell
you I don't I I never think about World
War two until I come over here I watched
that Ken Burns the war which is like a
90 [ __ ] part one out each each one
was like one hour long about the war and
every time I fly over here it's not till
I get over Great Britain and you just
think about those spits foot fires and
the Blitzkrieg and all of that [ __ ]
Winston Churchill then you've come onto
the mainland you start thinking about
the Battle of the Bulge Dresden all of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] and I was actually
watching this documentary here and it
was in German so I couldn't tell is like
wow they're [ __ ] they're also talking
about World War two I figured they'd
want to shy away from it you know what I
mean the same way I don't watch
highlights from last year's Superbowl
I don't want to see those Eagles win
either right but they were talking about
I could tell what they were talking
about cuz I'd heard about it before was
this top-secret now basically a jet that
they were just on the verge of like
developing which just would have been a
[ __ ] game changer like how far ahead
Germany was with all of their technology
I remember hearing I've talked about
this [ __ ] before like if you killed a
German soldier as an American you
dropped your machine gun and picked up
there says was like [ __ ] liquid cool
or something like that
I remember hearing some German tank
commanders saying one tiger was better
than three Sherman's but the Americans
always had four you know typical us we
just treated it like a food court we
just piled on instead of the food it was
with weaponry and we were able to get
them but some historians suck I look up
this [ __ ] jet first German jet World
War two yeah this [ __ ] thing and it
looked just like the Spitfire but it had
like two jet engines on it so the only
thing I could think like what the [ __ ]
would you do how quickly that thing
could get up on you what would you try
to be like Tom Cruise in that drug movie
will you just slow down and the feds got
to keep going by you you know I think
that's works if somebody's not trying to
[ __ ] shoot you out of the sky so I
think that that's probably what they
focus on over here they focus on how
good their weapons were rather than
their you know missteps in society it
was called the me sure Schmidt me its
262 nicknamed the schwabe I'm sure I'm
saying this one it's German for the
swallow was the world's first
operational jet powered fighter aircraft
that's what it was like basically a
jet-powered [ __ ] two-seater design
work started before World War two began
but problems with the engine which means
people died testing it out
buh buh the me 6262 is faster and more
heavily armed than any allied fighter
including the British of jet-powered
Gloster Meteor look at that big clunky
hunk of [ __ ] I thought I mean I
shouldn't talk the Americans didn't have
one but Jesus is that an ugly as [ __ ]
plane the German one doesn't look bad it
just looks like their what they had the
English had the Spitfire I don't forget
what we had the Cadillac I don't I don't
[ __ ] know a [ __ ] about this stuff but
anyways I was watching I found that that
that was definitely interesting and you
know what is you know how they always
make fun of the ignorant American the
fat American and all that [ __ ] you know
what is a through-line of kunti behavior
is people getting off an international
flight and doing that fast walk I mean
you see people cutting off old people in
all of this [ __ ] just trying to not get
in you know trying to get as far up you
know to get through customs as possible
it's really [ __ ] horrific I always
laugh thinking like where are you going
you know where the [ __ ] anybody going
dude it's already another flight in
front of you you know we you know you're
gonna get there first and you'll be
first and [ __ ] line maybe it works I
don't know I don't life's too short to
run through a [ __ ] airport with your
luggage if you're not trying to catch a
plane you're already landed what are you
doing just sit on your phone play a
little [ __ ] solitaire and then talk
to the guy up there you know I didn't
know what to say cuz you only landed
when I landed in Munich I didn't know
usually I have work papers and I was
sitting there thinking like [ __ ] man I
don't have any [ __ ] work papers and I
get up there so I try to look all chill
and [ __ ] right the lady doesn't ask me
anything and the guy behind her is like
[ __ ] and he's like I've seen skies him
desire that's right and I'm like he's
just trained at a man he's just training
him and I'm working up this lie in my
head that I'm meeting my wife in Cologne
Germany and she's coming over from
London could could it be any more
convoluted like really you guys are
beginning your European vacay
in Cologne Germany do you have family
there did they just put up a new [ __ ]
ferris wheel what though he going to
that [ __ ] giant whorehouse there
which I didn't know existed had no idea
that [ __ ] thing existed until I
[ __ ] looked up things to do in
Cologne because I got a whole day
tomorrow
I just want to go out and buy a pair of
[ __ ] adidas over here that they don't
have stateside I'm not looking for 20
floors of [ __ ] here anyways so I make
it through they stamp my passport I
think I'm all good and then this [ __ ]
cop is just like gutentag hello and I'm
like hey what's up he goes ah where
you're going I want to be where the [ __ ]
are you going you mean what am I doing
here Eddie stamp the [ __ ] thing
didn't I tell him the stupid [ __ ] about
my wife coming over he goes is this the
only place we're going to be on
gentlemen I was like I mean Cologne
Munich Berlin where else and I'm like
Warsaw Prague hungry he goes how long he
gonna be over here like until the 14th
he's like a January I was like yeah then
I might kick and he starts walking
towards this door with my passport I'm
like jesus [ __ ] christ here we go
right and then he just turns around and
gives it to me and I was just like so
then I text my [ __ ] tour guy over
here I was like do I need work papers
he's like no you're all good so I went
through that whole [ __ ] what was that
movie there with that [ __ ] guy he has
the drugs tape to him I can't remember
[ __ ] anything I end up having that
moment I didn't even need to so anyway
so I'm here I'm obviously jet-lagged but
my hour is ready to go and I plan on
kicking the [ __ ] out of people right
through Europe and this is gonna be a
thrash so my only thing I need to do is
I need to get my kiddo some shell toes
get my wife some sneakers to get myself
some sneakers and other than that all I
do when I go to new countries cuz I
don't like clutter is I you know that
little flag you buy that people selling
their coat I just buy that thing and
I've never sewed them onto anything I
just keep them in a little plastic bag
which by the way I saw this thing where
people try to break the record to see
all the country go to every country in
the [ __ ] world first of all it's like
what country do you come from where your
country doesn't have beef with any other
nation you know what I mean Jesus Christ
the way though they did [ __ ] whackin
people nowadays but anyways it's like
some people done it by the time they're
like in their 20s then I read this one
guy we say sorry that he started to do
it but then after you know he got to 127
countries and he realized that he wasn't
traveling he wasn't seeing anything he
was just going there and just you know
you know flying all the way to China and
getting like a [ __ ] you know some
[ __ ] shrimp fried rice and then just
flying on to [ __ ] Thailand and doing
whatever the [ __ ] he did there you know
stand next to an elephant and take a
picture and so it's like not travelling
is what the guy was saying so I don't
know am i babbling right now I probably
have [ __ ] jet-lagged here oh my god
did you guys see I'm gonna try to get
more into like pop culture to expand the
reach of my podcast oh my god Madonna
went up at this this legendary gay Club
and showed off what some people were
saying with a brand new ass trying to
say she got ass implants all right and
I'm like okay you know why the [ __ ]
would you get a brand new ass in your
sixties why would you get a new ass
anyways I don't understand that one you
know what I mean I don't really
understand the tits I don't understand
taking anything and putting it in your
body that you can't kind of get rid of
you don't mean [ __ ] it out I mean I'm
[ __ ] what are you know I can see what
those [ __ ] things look like but
anyway something's going like oh my god
she's lost her [ __ ] mind and then I
find out that she has a new album coming
out nobody's really been talking about
her it was [ __ ] brilliant
I bet it wasn't even real I bet she just
went down to a joke shop you know
they're phony
British accent right you know put these
fake ads in the back of me pads promote
me new album
what's in albums what's a new album
called huh
songs about coming something about the
some about some about sex
anyways let's see fake ass implants
let's see what these things look like
are these like oh my [ __ ] god oh my
god what enough all those art in
[Music]
somebody's ass I'm like why is this so
much space in the butt crack it was
cleavage um alright this is just all
calling out people with butt implants
this is something that guys get blamed
for it and you know this is chicks just
this is classic chick on chick hate and
they're gonna [ __ ] they're gonna
[ __ ] trashed sheets I want to see
what it looks like oh my god oh my god
what the [ __ ] that can't be [ __ ] real
I don't understand what why do people do
[ __ ] like this to themselves because of
the pressure they're [ __ ] me a [ __ ]
that's not the pressure you gave into it
alright there's a lot of pressure out
there they have a full head of [ __ ]
wavy hair you know this [ __ ]
transparent [ __ ] jackass doesn't give
in to it why the [ __ ] are you you know
[ __ ] blame society all right what do
ass implants look like Google must be
like oh my god this guy's dumb I want to
know what they look like
people feel butt implants oh my god that
just like those giant silicone [ __ ]
things
he's [ __ ] lazy [ __ ] just go do
some squats go do some squats and just
admit
that you're not [ __ ] Jennifer Lopez
whoever the [ __ ] has the best ass right
now anyways dude I should do that
I've been threatening to get hair plugs
right out here in Eastern Europe you
know not Eastern Europe yet but what I
consider Eastern Europe anything that
was behind the communist bloc when I go
to [ __ ] the other side of Berlin at
the east side of Berlin I'm gonna get
some [ __ ] take stem cells shot in my
head and I'm gonna come back with this
ridiculous [ __ ] lion's mane of ginger
hair and you guys are all gonna be like
oh my god what the [ __ ] did you guys see
Bill's [ __ ] hair plugs and eventually
be like hey man he's got a new special
coming out well I'm gonna I'm gonna
[ __ ]
I mean Madonna's the master at it you
know I'd be lucky to stick around for
half as long as she has so I mean that's
what you got to do maybe I should do it
you know you guys I don't watch Fight
Club because it triggers me it makes me
not like my body and I just feel like
Brad Pitt is just he's just he's what do
they say he's just setting the bar too
high I can't like I I just don't
understand why nobody calls these women
out like how [ __ ] self-involved are
you that you're looking at a movie star
and you start thinking like oh I have to
compete with that
no no just appreciate compete with that
you're not even in the same [ __ ]
solar system is that I can throw a
football but I don't look at an NFL
quarterback and be like why does he have
to throw it so hard why does he have to
be so accurate
anyways Jesus Christ the Internet my god
comedians from a fellow comedian please
stop attacking other comedians what are
we doing we need to circle the wagons
here jesus [ __ ] christ
don't comedians get enough [ __ ] we're
gonna sit here and [ __ ] attack each
other
the [ __ ] are we doing I feel like this
is like at the end of the Blair Witch
when those kids kept them ending up in
the same place in the woods and they
were losing their [ __ ] minds this is
what's going on well I don't I don't
understand how a comedian could trash
another comedian publicly like that
I mean amongst your friends you guys
guys a hack this guy stinks Oh blah blah
blah blah blah I like this guy you know
everybody does that and every [ __ ]
but to go on there and then to actually
talk about what subjects should or
shouldn't be discussed I mean there's
like comedians out there
they sound like Tipper Gore back in the
80s when she was freaking out about hair
medaled
I think there's bigger problems in the
world then someone going on stage trying
out new jokes that he's not putting out
to the world he's just working on them
that's all that was happening Jesus
Christ I think some of the [ __ ] [ __ ]
I've said on stage just [ __ ] around
and it leads to something it's part of
it so that's like somebody's saying like
listening to the first version of a hit
song going oh my god that [ __ ] sucks
it's like yeah well we're working on it
how the [ __ ] could somebody [ __ ] blow
everybody's acting not everybody but
there's people out there they're acting
like [ __ ] my god they're acting like
soccer moms it's just a it's just a
[ __ ] weird goddamn time and anyways
it's hard enough right now to try to
avoid a [ __ ] scandal you're not even
looking for we don't need to be
attacking each other right so god bless
all the comedian's out there
god bless it whatever the [ __ ] it is
they're trying to do they're trying to
be funny you know and let these [ __ ]
non comedians say what you shouldn't
shouldn't joke about let them sound
stupid like that jesus [ __ ] christ
you remember tipper gore remember that
lady way back in the day poor al you
imagine that I bet he listened to all
that but he listened to Motley Crue at
all of them back in the day
I wish I could do a [ __ ] algo
impression it's sink [ __ ] kickstart
my heart in the Al Gore voice alright
let me I to set the other night at the
Comedy Store late night and I was just
in a stupid mood and the piano player
was laughing and I just started playing
to him and I said like two or three
[ __ ] things that I would never I
would never put in a special I would
never ever was just and it wouldn't it
wouldn't even have worked in that room
at like eight nine o'clock at night nine
ten o'clock but once you go on the other
side of midnight it just becomes like a
different [ __ ] thing now alright if
anyone were to film that whatever the
[ __ ] it is I was talking until [ __ ] did
I talk about don't say it don't say that
[ __ ] say it right one of those sets
if all of a sudden now somebody at 8:00
in the morning is eating their toast and
then somebody says it you know what I
mean it's like for as much as a dick as
I am you know if I go to church if I
ever go to church go like once a [ __ ]
here when I go there I don't act the way
I acted the [ __ ] Comedy Store nor
would I and I wouldn't feel like if what
I said at The Comedy Store I then said
in a church if people got offended
I wouldn't then feel like I was having a
Lenny Bruce moment and I was [ __ ]
being censored yeah there's a time and a
place for things it's just like you know
to just [ __ ] take somebody there
working on this [ __ ] doing what they're
supposed to be doing and then you take
it and [ __ ] throw it and everybody's
face at 9:00 in the morning on Twitter
maybe they said well oh no [ __ ] it's
like jesus [ __ ] christ I don't know
it's a really people just to let you
know making jokes about really dark
things a lot of times is a way to avoid
the pain it doesn't mean you don't care
about it that's really the way that is
such like page one of comedy if you
don't understand that then you don't
know what you're talking about and you
really need to
I think anyways there's my little
[ __ ] two cents of it jesus [ __ ]
christ I can't I can't [ __ ] imagine I
can't ever [ __ ] imagine telling a
comic what the [ __ ] they should be
saying on stage yet let alone trying to
incite other people who aren't comedians
to [ __ ] share that point of view if I
did that evidently nowadays I would be a
progressive liberal it used to be the
hard core right what is going on the
world has gone mad down is up up is down
black is white what the [ __ ] all right
darling I'm and I'm not trashing anybody
I'm just [ __ ] say it guys don't
[ __ ] pick on each other we're gonna
get enough [ __ ] out there evidently from
butthurt Ali over there
all right Dollar Shave Club everybody
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to look feel and smell your best
you never have to go to the store if
you're ever pushing a mop at [ __ ] MIT
and your [ __ ] butt itches and you
can't [ __ ] solve the math problem
it's cuz you didn't use a one wipe
challi uh little Good Will Hunting
little dollar shave club there that's
called a mashup I believe the kids call
it a mashup that's because they deliver
everything you need right to your door
and they keep you fully stocked on what
you use so you don't run out here's how
it works
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for they have you covered
head to toe for your hair your skin your
okay to stay your hair and just assume
that people aren't bald who are reading
this really triggers me and I really
feel that everybody at Dollar Shave Club
could use should lose their jobs so I
can feel better your face you name it
they have it and they what do you mean
you name it they have it even child
pornography I'm triggered again I need
Gillette to Auto apologize just because
they make shave stuff too and when I see
that it reminds me of this read sorry
that was my impression of 20/20 around
September if this continues and
have this new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products you use you determine what you
want and when you want it and it shows
up right at your Dilla from what once a
month to once every six months plus with
their handsome discount the more you buy
the more you save
and right now jolly shape club has a
bunch of status sets you can try for
just five dollars like their oral care
kit
after that the restock box ships regular
size products and a regular price get
your start starter set for just five
dollars right now at dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's dollarshaveclub.com / / this
is how dumb I am and how bad I was at
math when I was watching Good Will
Hunting they have this amazing
establishing shot of MIT some sort of
giant dome and I didn't recognize what
it was I thought they were in Rome I
thought it was some old building and
then all of a sudden he was inside
mopping the floor I was like oh I guess
that's what MIT looks like I mean I'd
seen it you drive by if I remember
correctly you go by it over a bridge
isn't it right off Kenmore Square you go
over that bridge but there's always
trees sort of obstructing it you know I
don't know math triggers me butcher box
everybody butcher box delivers healthy
100% grass-fed and grass-finished beef
free-range organic chicken at Heritage
bread pork the incredible quality of
butcher box meats starts with the
commitment to raising animals humanely
and free of antibiotics and hormones
cook with peace of mind knowing you are
eating healthy high-quality meat each
box comes with at least eight to 11
pounds of meat which is enough for 24
individual sized meals unless you're a
[ __ ] binge eating fat [ __ ] then you
know it's probably an overnight snack
well I gotta have me twelve pork chops
before I go to bed now you can choose
from five different box types all beef
beef and chicken beef and pork mix box
custom box which lets you choose your
own cuts and now announcing our new
brand of protein wild Alaskan salmon
this isn't just Alaskan salmon
this is wild Alaskans
all right you give this you give this
fish a couple of shots that's showing
its tits that I'm sorry butcher box [ __ ]
butcher buck shows their pure
sustainably harvested salmon from
Bristol Bay Alaska unlike any salmon
you'll find in your local stores how do
you know what's from there they got a
certain style certain swagger the way
they move their tail literally it's red
color means that this salmon is as fresh
as nutrient and nutrient rich as it gets
oh yeah for $20 off your first box and
two pounds of free salmon go to butcher
box com slash burn enter bur b you are r
that's butcher box calm and enter bur be
you are our 27 minutes of Jesus it flies
by Liverpool got their first loss of the
year I missed the game I couldn't find
it here I was watching some sort of
soccer over here where they had this
really small net what is that indoor
soccer look like was outside and there
was some sort of basketball going on and
all they were doing was speaking in
German everybody was talking in German
and then the crowd was chanting defense
in English it's weird it's where the
words that come you know I mean I guess
I used blitzkrieg do I I don't think I
do anyways yeah so I just been I
couldn't find the [ __ ] game
congratulations - Man City I didn't
realize I know it was like a huge deal
when they won an understatement a few
years ago they came out of [ __ ]
nowhere and won the whole goddamn thing
and I guess they handled Liverpool
pretty nicely some sort of controversial
[ __ ] goal I don't know what happened
but the way my brain works is like [ __ ]
when do we play these guys again and we
got to figure out how to beat him or
we're gonna lose in the playoffs and
then it's just like oh wait they don't
have playoffs it's just the end of the
year whoever has the most points
whatever the [ __ ] they call it which I
can't quite do you gets three points for
a win and one for a decision I don't
[ __ ] know dude I'm so [ __ ] jet lag
I just was on YouTube and I think I just
learned how to play snooker
but anyways then do you know they don't
want the [ __ ] play they could like
lose to them every time they [ __ ]
play him but still win the whole thing
makes no stakes no [ __ ] sense anyways
I got a I got a kill a date tomorrow
here in Cologne Germany what is there to
do here is there a good sneaker store
here I don't want to go to like the
Adidas stores there a place where they
have like you know a bunch of different
like you know adidas that you wouldn't
get at the Adidas store you know like a
undefeated type store you know what I
mean one of those types of stores you
know what I mean the ones with a super
super [ __ ] crazy sneaker head type
[ __ ] people go to that's what I want
to go to because I have to come back
with some original [ __ ] I can't just
come back with a pair of Run DMC looking
[ __ ] shell-toes that you know my wife
and kid could have got down the [ __ ]
Street at the mall you know what I mean
so help me out if you can send me a
tweet all right and all right I think
that's it
god bless you all thank you to everybody
who's coming out to my show tomorrow
night I'm so psyched to be over here
with one of my great friends in the
world Paul virzi club soda Kenny we're
gonna have a great time over here and
thank you to everybody that's coming up
to the shows yeah that's it I'm really
looking forward to this and I don't know
feels weird to end on something positive
but I think I'm going to alright so have
a great weekend you [ __ ] and I'll check
in up talk to you on Monday
enjoy the music and there'll be another
half hour great greatest hits from a
Thursday afternoon podcast from I don't
know some [ __ ] Thursday earlier this
year or years ago
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill pur and it
is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday January 3rd 2011 do you guys have
a nice New Year's I hope you had a nice
holiday seriously before I uh
before I say cont for the first time on
a podcast this year officially that one
wasn't official that was just me stating
it like in a court of law
as in I asked the defendant where he was
coming from and he told me quote to go
[ __ ] myself
see now that lawyer is not saying is
saying the f-word but it's it's not that
example made no goddamn sense whatsoever
um anyways I hope you guys all had a
Merry Christmas and a Happy New Year and
all that now that you back at work you
know is this a way this is a weird week
this is another weird week last week was
the weird depressing week unless you're
a a college student or something or or
you know a kid you living at home or
some [ __ ] then it's great cuz you got
time off from school everything's
awesome you're going sledding alright
you make a nice balls you're throwing
them at the fat kid down the street
right the ice ball [ __ ] snowball
right put a nice chunk of ice in there
you pack it with some powdery stuff and
you say hey you want to have a snowball
fight right you can't oh my god they're
finally including me Jesus it's been so
rough since July when they left at my
man tits town at the town pool and he
thinks he's included right I love all
the mean [ __ ] who were laughing at this
right now and then what'd he do bring
him over right he throws a couple of
[ __ ] Colorado snowballs now that
powdery [ __ ] at you and then you [ __ ]
set him up like Pat Patterson when he
took out the [ __ ] brass knuckles when
he beat Ted DiBiase for the
Intercontinental Championship in 1980
but you knew that maybe it was 81 I
don't [ __ ] remember right you [ __ ]
nail that fatty right in the side of his
head he goes down he cries half his face
goes numb he gets Bell palsy from laying
in that half fro
and puddle and all your friends laugh
you don't even help him up and he's
laying there in his dirty orange [ __ ]
puffy coat that he just got for
Christmas where does he go he goes back
inside and sits down and plays [ __ ]
video games until he's 36 and that's the
first time he discovers Craigslist you
know with the quivering voice and
trembling fingers he picks up the old
rotary phone I don't know where I'm
going with this I think initially I was
gonna make fun the kids don't even do
this [ __ ] anymore because they're too
busy being inside playing video games
and then just sort of spun off to a
vignette of my childhood you know it's
funny is that that whole thing never
really happened I was on both sides of
that snowball Jesus that was pathetic
you know I think it's important in life
to remember that at some point you were
on the wrong side of a nice snowball am
I really just gonna do the mock gave
voice to just get out of every difficult
comedy moment I think I'm going to I've
been doing it for the first three years
of this podcast people do you understand
that I am basically about a year and a
half away from being five years into
this podcast and actually getting to do
a reunion show with myself you know
thicker head of hair
five pounds lighter just as much as a
douche just as much of a douche that's
something in 2011 I would like to have
more sentences that make sense
you guys make any new year's resolutions
well I can't hear them so shut up are
you an idiot you can sit there and
rattle them off look at that goddamn
cubicle you're really gonna sit in that
[ __ ] thing for another year are you
that's right look down in shame at your
belt buckle that's snazzy little belt
buckle that you bought that you thought
would set off your suit you know make
people see at the gas station standing
there thinking that you actually have
some sort of a [ __ ] desk where you
can look across at somebody else who you
wield a little bit of power
this is actually creeping me out I don't
want to make somebody do something crazy
it's okay a cubicle is just a stepping
stone to a cubicle that's even larger
and then one day being the final three
people to get the corner office and then
you realize that you've been replaced by
a [ __ ] robot speaking of which I got
to find this email that somebody sent me
um if I was organized I would have heard
it blue new in the meantime my goals
this year is I'm finally gonna rehab the
[ __ ] torn abdomen muscle that I
[ __ ] up at a pirate's game I'm going
on three [ __ ] years three years ago I
tried to show that I could go into the
pike position at 40 years of age okay
goddamn it I did it but I didn't stretch
and I think I talked to you guys about
this right after I did it goddamn and
I've been doing the podcast long enough
go back to like July of 2008 somewhere
in there I went to a Pirates game when I
was working the Pittsburgh improv and I
wanted to show off what great shape I
was in and Here I am three years later
still dealing with two and a half years
later still didn't want that what the
hell is in oh they are watching yeah so
anyways let me let me before I get into
the conspiracy theory which I took a
break from in 2010 because I wanted to
actually enjoy my life yeah I want to
rehab it anybody can give me some WebMD
free advice come on there's got to be a
personal trainer out there I know when
you tear an abdomen muscle he's supposed
to rest it and then after you rest it
from 1 to 4 weeks
in court according to my stomach hurts
and I don't know why dot-com he's
supposed to rest it for 1 to 4 weeks and
then begin doing some sort of rehab
which you know I don't know how to do it
I found just sitting there in the plank
position helps for you yoga people out
there it's sort of like the push-up
position but you're on your forearms
that seemed to have helped it but I
and I [ __ ] it up the other day and
it's really frustrating it's frustrating
so anyways yeah when I rehab that I
wouldn't want to eat better this year
and I want to continue to not drink for
as long as I can I'm going for a hundred
days I'm going for 100 days in fact
listen to this fuckos
I went to I went to the Rose Bowl this
year and I did not drink I did not drink
and I know there's a lot of you who are
disappointed that I didn't drink because
you want me to fill up your life with a
hilarious story of me making an ass of
myself once again to kick off a new year
well goddamn it I didn't but I stood
around and I watched enough other people
[ __ ] do it and I still have plenty of
stories and I got the brain cells to
remember him
it's a [ __ ] awesome game it was
Wisconsin versus TCU and I was like most
people like who the [ __ ] is TCU and then
you look in the program let me go grab
the Rose Bowl program hang on one second
on this podcast alright I'm back so
here's the Rose Bowl program and
basically the Rose Bowl this year if you
were going to turn it into a novel
you're gonna turn it into an awful
made-for-tv movie this was a like I
guess it was a story about respect
alright in that you know people barely
respect Wisconsin because they never go
to the Rose Bowl I can't remember the
last time they won the Big Ten
championship but they finally want it
they want it and they beat the likes of
let's let's see you let's see who they
beat alright let's go through their
whole [ __ ] season here really quickly
stop rolling your eyes you [ __ ]
commie non-sports fan [ __ ] alright start
off the year they beat UNLV these are
the cupcake games early in the end and
they beat San Jose State Arizona State
is
pac-10 team austin peay who is that
somebody's name do they play like one
guy then they beat Michigan State then
they beat Minnesota they beat Ohio State
right Big Ten Iowa Purdue you've heard
of these teams Indiana Michigan one of
those teams they actually lost two but I
went by too quickly Northwestern you
know they played some [ __ ] teams
TCU on the other hand didn't place [ __ ]
so Casey down there and outside of
Dallas Texas Texas Christian oh Jesus
University and you're wondering why no
one gives a [ __ ] about the Mountain West
program I want you to write me and tell
me just exactly ok Oregon State - that's
pac-10 that's Tennessee Tech this is
their undefeated season they beat Oregon
State Tennessee Tech Baylor SMU Colorado
State Wyoming BYU air force UNLV Utah
San Diego State New Mexico that was
their undefeated season and this sitting
there scratching the top of their
[ __ ] heads wondering why there didn't
that people are questioning their record
alright so here's the deal I'm sitting
there going alright I like this big ten
even though the big ten isn't what it
used to be considering they went oh and
five on [ __ ] New Year's Day
who doesn't like an underdog so I'm
going well [ __ ] it man I'm gonna root
for TCU even though they have Christian
oh jeez in the middle of their [ __ ]
name which you know what that means they
automatically think they're better than
everybody else and Jesus loves us best
despite the fact that they're preaching
that everybody needs to be more
understanding like Jesus
somehow they miss the irony of the fact
that they feel like they're the chosen
ones like all stupid [ __ ] religions
do right Jewish people think they are
the chosen ones Christian's think they
are the chosen ones Muslim thinks that
you know what you guys are all a bunch
of douche bags all right none of you
matter that's why there's so many of us
if we were special they'd only be like
nine of us once there's seven billion of
anything I mean
but we're not special anymore okay do
you understand that
we're like socks you know actually some
poor people can afford socks the socks
are still important to some people you
know I don't want to [ __ ] say it's at
ECU they gotta [ __ ] be in their bonnet
about how nobody's respecting them so
I'm sitting there this is before I
talked to anybody from TCU I just saw
right you know purple and black does a
decent colors man I like those Wisconsin
I'm looking at all these fatties from
Wisconsin you know walking around just
horrible horrible shape I think when you
know when Europeans look at America and
they think of the fat [ __ ] you know I
think I don't know I think they date
they send away for a Wisconsin broche
University brochure every year I don't
know what because Jesus Christ
those were some healthy [ __ ] people
all right evidently the recession has
not hit Wisconsin yet because those
people have plenty of money for extra
food so anyway so I'm sitting there and
uh we start to walk into the game right
me and three of my buddies were okay and
i don't name names on this [ __ ] thing
we go to walk into this goddamn thing
and i start looking around after Oh
after a wonderful tailgate we really did
it up this year plenty of booze which I
did not partake in
I brought a 12-pack of water go ahead
email me call me a [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] I feel great you [ __ ] [ __ ] look
I'm still defensive about it you know at
least I'm one of those those those I'm
not a preachy sober person I'm not going
like you know why do you do that what
are you what are you running from I know
why you're doing it cuz it's [ __ ] fun
and I'd still be doing if my head didn't
get three times the size of its usual
enormous size you know my head when I'm
not boozing looks like one of the moons
of Jupiter okay i don't--hey
I don't need to continue adding to it
you know and then have it be like Pluto
and then scientists can [ __ ] debate
on whether or not it's a [ __ ] planet
all right [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] there
you go see I needed the help there the F
word for me is is my my one of those
things the HGH of my [ __ ] comedy all
right and I will continue to use it and
I don't give a [ __ ] cuz they're not
banned in my industry anyways so what
was I saying
alright so we had a great tailgate we
show up I've came in the back way this
this this year alright we parked right
along the fence we were right near the
clubhouse on the golf course and then
you can I could literally see one of the
lights you know that lights up the
stadium so we were right there there was
no way we were getting lost this year
actually brought a frying pan brought
some eggs
we had burgers hotdogs steak we had [ __ ]
to throw in the omelets cheese
everything you want we had a spatula we
brought tongs we had napkins we had a
[ __ ] garbage bag we had a grill bag
of charcoal four bags of [ __ ] ice oh
cool we had everything we had [ __ ]
corn chips we had salsa we had two
bottles of mustard whole jar of [ __ ]
pickles ketchup we had everything we had
we had we had real Forks and steak
knives for the steaks we had everything
except for a [ __ ] table god next year
is gonna be the per every year two
bottles of Crown Royal a case of [ __ ]
beer we we were we were ready to go we
even had orange juice for the [ __ ]
eggs we were ready to go and we forgot a
goddamn table so anyways we start the
day off with one of the best [ __ ]
omelets you ever gonna have New Year's
Day sitting on a golf course on a sunny
day knowing the rest of the goddamn
country snowed in screaming at some
ticket agent that they got to get back
to Albuquerque before they yak you know
shits the bed right we forgot a goddamn
table which isn't bad when you eat a
nama but when you
the [ __ ] steak that's an inch and a
half thick that's been cooked at best
rare supposed to be medium-rare
okay it was it was just medium-rare what
happens is we got it on a paper plate
and as you use pressure to cut into that
it creases in the middle and you see
this puddle of grease it just starts
coming it comes close to your balls and
then goes away just like the tide coming
in and you sitting there going you know
I really should I just dripped the rest
of this grease down into the grass
kill a couple of ladybugs and then
continue on with the eating process but
it tastes so [ __ ] good you go you
know and I think I can do it one more
time and then you do it and what happens
it [ __ ] rolls right off onto your
jeans and you ever notice I don't give a
[ __ ] what you spill where you spill it
you could have your arms outstretched if
you spill any sort of liquid it not only
does it land in your crotch it lands
right at the head of your dick so it
always looks like you pissed your pants
so that's what I look like I had grease
on the front of my pants I mean while
I'm sitting here watching all these
Wisconsin fans walking around and I got
these candy striped [ __ ] overalls
they look like Richard Simmons shorts if
you [ __ ] mugged him and cleaned out
his closet of early 80s [ __ ] gayest
running shorts ever and you somehow turn
them into overalls you know be one thing
if women were wearing them that'd be
kind of hot right but there was a bunch
of guys wearing them too they are they
all look like they look like it look
like a jugglers convention it's the best
way to put it so I'm sitting there guy
man I like the big ten I want to root
for Wisconsin then every once in a while
because it seemed to be like 80% 75%
maybe 70 at the smallest Wisconsin fans
and then TCU so you know who doesn't
like an underdog so I start walking
towards the stadium right and I'm
thinking I'm gonna go for TCU [ __ ] this
I hope this little Mountain West
whatever [ __ ] I don't know conference
it from huh
I hope these guys win and I start going
up to the stadium and one of my buddies
elbows mean he turned around he points
to these TCU fans in this guy
is wearing brown loafers these light
purple like corduroy Dockers with the
TCU emblem and then like a v-neck
sweater and like these Raybon [ __ ]
risky business sunglasses on and he I
like if you if you were casting a movie
do you guys see Facebook that Facebook
social network do you know how like the
Harvard guys were this is what this guy
looked like and I was like oh my are you
serious is this guy a an anomaly or is
this really what TCU was all about my
buddy literally goes to me he goes
that's it I'm rooting for Wisconsin you
know I look at this [ __ ] guy and I
and I was sitting there going you know
what I think he's right nah maybe it's
just this one [ __ ] guy and then I see
another guy he has on a purple [ __ ]
blazer with gold buttons a white shirt
some pleated slacks and loafers to the
game and all of a sudden I started
looking at these it's not all of them
but I could 15% of him are dressed this
way looking like those rich kids who
[ __ ] you know air-quote accidentally
kill their date you know and then they
say it was consensual because she wanted
rough sex too and that daddy has enough
[ __ ] money to get him out of it
that's what they started looking like so
I'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this I'm rooting
for Wisconsin now we're in the crush to
get in the game and I look in front of
me and there's this pasty fat [ __ ]
Wisconsin fan in front of me with the
Wisconsin hat turned around and I don't
know if it was dry skin or eczema
he had a perfect band of it going around
the back of his you know his hairline at
the back of his head and the flakes of
it were on the back of his sweatshirt I
know I hope you're not eating okay so
I'm looking at him going oh horrified
absolutely horrified and then I'm
turning around I'm looking at these
[ __ ] slack and sport coat wearing
douche bags and
at that point I didn't know who I was
for I was actually hoping that during
the flyover one of the Jets would go to
the crowd and they could just start all
over again it was it was horrific worst
group of fans I've seen in in three
years granted I was sober this time and
I could actually remember this so I go
into the stadium right and lo and behold
I'm in the TCU section right and I'm
like okay I don't know if I like this
and I just said all signage here start
here take say yeah this girl like three
rows back Jase yeah you come on come on
frogs and I go frogs
did the [ __ ] I don't know what they
were we got to give it to Wisconsin
Badger is a badass [ __ ] ham TCU
Horned Frogs okay and in that their
mascot look I don't it looks like
something out of like that Star Wars bar
scene you know and the guys go frog come
on TCU TCU and I'm looking at the girls
and they they have their jeans tucked
into their cowboy boots like they're in
that band great white you know and then
on top they have like these dime-store
Dolly Parton cowboy hats on and I was
like oh my god I [ __ ] hate these
people
and at that point I was sitting right in
the middle of them and I immediately
just became a Wisconsin fan now in
defense of TCU I think if I was hanging
in the Wisconsin section I would root I
would have rooted for TCU I would have
rooted for TCU you know the middle of me
just screaming that tastes Iggy you come
out frogs I can't tell if Nia just left
or the guy downstairs yelled at me oh
that's a dog okay my fault or it's Mel
Blanc could anybody imitate a dog
barking better than that guy anyways
let's plow ahead here so then I just sat
there and just was rooting for Wisconsin
and I just want it out and I just
another thing too that is really [ __ ]
annoying about TCU fans okay is
no matter what's going on during the
game they have a reason to [ __ ] put
their hands in the air so you can't see
the [ __ ] game anytime it was third
down they had this gay little thing well
you know you make the I'm ok sign they
would do that signifying third down and
then they would just sort of shake their
hands like you just in case you don't
know it down it and everybody so it's
like third down and anybody who watches
football knows third down is a really
important [ __ ] down as a fan who
played have paid a fuckload for the
ticket you want to see what happened and
these [ __ ] idiots are so busy going
to to Lou you couldn't see anything then
not to mention there's fat [ __ ] in
front of me who from the size of her
should have been a Wisconsin fan but
then again I've been to Houston Texas
okay those people like their barbecue to
they these are the people that really
make America look bad it's the [ __ ]
middle of the country you goddamn people
I don't know what your problem is is
because you're landlocked
don't they have swimming pools where you
people could do a couple of laps people
on the coasts are in shape
alright Seattle all the way down to San
Diego these [ __ ] are in shape
go ahead yeah
San Diego go right up the coast Los
Angeles San Francisco or a Portland
Oregon they're in shape
Seattle they're in shape Vancouver I
even leave the country and they're
[ __ ] in shape you start getting out
there Nebraska Iowa Wisconsin huh
[ __ ] people are horrific other than
Florida Florida doesn't count
alright Florida is I don't know what it
is it's like the ball bag everybody says
it looks like a dick to me it looks like
a [ __ ] 56 year old scrotum just hang
in there
after the dick got lopped off anyways so
they handed out the it like like them
doing that third down thing wasn't
enough they handed out these [ __ ]
little purple like rags
okay first of all stealing from the
Pittsburgh Steelers that's the Terrible
Towel they steal that and then on them
it said fear the Frog which they stole
from
Maryland fear the turtle right the first
school to actually admit that they have
a bad name a bad mascot [ __ ] name
so then what they would this [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] in front of me I swear to God
every goddamn play okay her [ __ ] team
would be we had endzone seats where it
was in the other end zone at Wisconsin's
10-yard line trying to drive in for a
score okay there there 90 yards away if
you're standing on the goal line
forget about being 40 50 [ __ ] rows up
in the goddamn stand and she would be
sitting there as she's talking to a
friend - that's what killed me
classic brought it again she's sitting
there shooting the [ __ ] you know she
probably went there for the tournament
of [ __ ] roses and she just kept it I
finally I tapped her on her fleshy
shoulder and she immediately took it as
I was saying put it down I said can you
just wave that can you wave it more in
your like in front of you which this is
the funniest thing ever she does and
immediately realizes that when she does
it she can't see the [ __ ] game
welcome to my world you fat [ __ ] that's
what I've been dealing with for the last
three [ __ ] quarters so then what she
did was she then switched it into her
left hand okay because not only is she a
fat [ __ ] she's a dumb fat [ __ ] okay
and the first moment when I tapped her
she was like oh this guy must be a
Wisconsin fan you know because he's
telling me to put it down then she
realizes oh it's in his way then she
waves it in front of her face and
realizes oh now I can't see and you
would think at that point light would
dawn on her [ __ ] fat head and she'd
be like oh I get it if I wave this thing
people behind me can't see the [ __ ]
game not this fat [ __ ] not this one she
[ __ ] puts it in the left hand and
starts waving like that like that's the
solution like she doesn't notice that
there's another [ __ ] 80,000 fans to
her [ __ ] left it was the worst and
it's times like those where I just times
like those were made for tasters Joyce
remember that coffee just brew up a nice
hot pot and you just dump it right over
can head that's what I would have liked
in a perfect world and as she screamed
from the scalding burns she would
collapse afterwards so maybe pass out
either way she would be out of my way
and I got to tell you that would be the
equivalent of three normal Americans who
live on the coasts who live near the
ocean hey you know what I just realized
that's how I'm gonna make my million
dollars
my multi-million dollar I can parachute
out of this goddamn business I've been
trying to come up with some [ __ ]
that I could sell for 1995 late at night
I think I just did you know I'm gonna
sell I'm gonna sell ocean water in
little salt shakers for 1995 that's what
I'm gonna do and I'm just gonna go you
know have you ever noticed how you know
people who live on the coast of this
country are in shape you don't and I'll
just show a bunch of good-looking people
running down the street with their knees
nice and high like the Wisconsin [ __ ]
marching band which was the [ __ ] just
running down the [ __ ] Street you know
high stepping it and then the white
version of high stepping which is
basically bringing our knees up to our
waist as opposed to the Grambling black
version where you basically you know you
couldn't do it in a dome stadium because
you would break your [ __ ] toes
whatever black people were trying we're
trying anyways so yeah I wish I would
sell it I would just say and then you
get any you know are you tired of being
fat in the middle of the country and
just so somebody has Cinnabon taking a
bite out of it and then just look at the
camera like you know throwing their arms
up low yeah I am sick of being a fat
[ __ ] you know you know they have
Cinnabons on the East Coast wired on the
west coast why aren't they fat [ __ ]
it's good I'll just I just spin it it's
because they live near the ocean and it
they're smelling that salt water in the
air
and I just make up a bunch of [ __ ] I'll
pay off some [ __ ] people in the FDA
it doesn't seem like a hard thing to do
considering half the drugs that could
approve nowadays and I'll just say it's
because of smelling salt water air that
you're able to eat Cinnabon and shut off
those [ __ ] pounds and I'll sell it
like little bottles of [ __ ] Cologne
to every fatty in the [ __ ] Midwest
and I'll make my money and then I'm
gonna move to Denmark and I'm gonna pay
ninety percent taxes yet have free
health insurance and you know in a
little Vespa I'm gonna go around those
little [ __ ] those little streets out
there I'm trying to put together
Scandinavian tour by the way this year
I'm really looking forward to that today
you know something like you I also lost
interest half way through that so that
was the Rose Bowl for me this year I
didn't drink I had a I had a [ __ ]
awesome time I remember the game
congratulations to taste you let's go
frogs congratulations to you horribly
horribly dress to you in beings just
horribly dressed trash white trash is
the only way to describe what I saw
there you guys really looked like you
never left the Greater Dallas area you
know I'm gonna go out on a limb here and
I would say I'm never gonna get an
opportunity to perform at that school
[Laughter]
and if I ever get an offer I'm gonna be
really suspect of it thinking that they
actually listen to this podcast oh my
god the dime-store [ __ ] Oh every the
woman women all dress like them that
Dolly Parton movie best a little
whorehouse in Texas except they were
serious they put on my best hat for this
one I saw a guy actually took a picture
of him or did i zoom into him I have
some video I got to give it to my web
guy of this guy he was dressed in a suit
with a big black Stetson looking like
[ __ ] jr. Ewing's standing you know if
it was the early 80s I would he would
have looked good you know but it's
[ __ ] 2011 dude it's time to let that
go you're [ __ ] oil man slash coke
dealer look from [ __ ] 1981 thirty
years later you're still rocking that
look like dead serious
dead serious these are the kind of
people that think like there's that you
can cure homosexuals you know and you
know like when those country singers
like need a hit so they just write a
song about how Great America is and
there too and the fans are too dumb to
see through the fact that they're just
trying to make money you know I like
America and if you don't like it the
[ __ ] out cuz it's the best goddamn
nation even though the schools are going
down the [ __ ] and just ignoring
everything speech speaking of which I
got a great underrated overrated here
this week that somebody sent in and you
know you guys know I'm a [ __ ] so I
couldn't put it any better than this guy
this guy says overrated the new year on
TV every [ __ ] year all these
celebrities come on and say how amazing
the new year is how is it how is it any
more amazing than the last the
population is still rising and people
are just getting more [ __ ] stupid and
fat you know for comedic purposes you
sort of said more fat stick more [ __ ]
fat and stupid see the alliteration
well [ __ ] stupid and fat you know
that's just like you know after you've
gone down the rollercoaster you gone
down ticking the big drop though you get
those little ones that don't even scare
you those little bunny hills but if you
say more [ __ ] fat and stupid [ __ ]
fat you get two of those in a row that's
like that's like going right down the
big one
anyways I'll help you out here the
population is still rising and people
are getting more [ __ ] fat and stupid
the banks are still stealing our money
our money spell a re
our money and and the politicians still
lie I don't see how it is anything more
than depressing and pathetic loved
you're special
thank you uh yeah I agree with you 100%
agree with you to the point it's so
[ __ ] depressing that I just got a dog
a couple years ago because no one else
seems to give a [ __ ] and in that the
line of that here's some conspiracy
theory for you somebody said bill that
they he wrote they are watching and
I got trashed for talking about
conspiracy theory I've been trash for
talking about those automated checkout
lines in the grocery store and saying
that I'm paranoid and I'm afraid of
Technology and all this technology is
just gonna help my life and make my life
more easier and why don't you trust
these big [ __ ] corporations basically
it's the [ __ ] that people are giving me
the same way people gave me [ __ ] for
trashing the Jets saying that the Jets
you know haven't done anything so I
don't know why they're [ __ ] Super
Bowl favorites what because the coach
said they're gonna win every [ __ ]
game you know this is this is the best
way I can sum up Rex Riley Rex Ryan Rex
Ryan is the Tila Tequila of NFL head
coaches famous for nothing in particular
he's never won anything yet everybody
knows who he is and is hanging on his
words like he has something to [ __ ]
say what cuz he dropped nine thousand
f-bombs on HBO he's famous for that he
wore a wig in a press conference and we
found out he has a foot fetish oh yeah
toss him right in there with Chuck null
[ __ ] ridiculous
by the way speaking of that the [ __ ] did
you know the Steelers finally looked
like the Steelers I thought that they
were gonna look like when Roethlisberger
came back that is a scary ask team and I
know they were just playing the Browns
but when Polamalu comes in the is
playing it's an entirely different team
so I'll you jet fans out there who are
excited that you beat that team I'm
telling you that's a different [ __ ]
team
I'm not even excited that the Patriots
beat them because I just don't think
that the Steelers are now starting to
click and they remind me of a certain
giant team from a few years ago that no
one was really paying attention to and
all of a sudden got hot in December and
lo and behold beat the 18 and OH
Patriots so oh and speaking of that my
season-long bet with Paul virzi I want
it I'm psyched I want it
I basically rattled off six victories in
a row against the spread
and put Paul very Paul virzi out of his
misery
you know the poor bastard the entire
year really felt like he was gonna beat
me just because I had never I and I
never really gambled because I I did it
like [ __ ] in 1989 let's see it one
and only time I did it I season tickets
to the Patriots we made the playoffs a
year before and all of a sudden we were
5 and 11 and I was like [ __ ] this I'm
getting some of my money back for you
know shelling out 250 bucks for season
tickets that's what you could get back
in the day before ESPN overhyped every
sport and people who don't even like
sports to go into games now so yeah I
want to get some my money back and I
remember the Buffalo Bills right before
they became the Buffalo Bills they had
all those guys they were a year away
from going to their first Super Bowl you
know four in a row winning four AFC
championships in a row one of the most
underrated accomplishments ever you know
basically because they got because he
lost four Super Bowls in a row so I mean
wait but anyways I decided to bet the
[ __ ] Buffalo Bills that year this is
off a memory this is what gambling does
and I remember that was the one [ __ ]
week the goddamn Patriots showed up in
won the game so I couldn't even enjoy it
and I lost like fifty bucks which when
you're only making 125 a week is a
tremendous blow so I never bet again I
never gambled against the spread for
like until this year and Paul versi who
you know has been doing it for years
going dude I called it I did this I did
that you got beat by a goddamn nerd I'm
just breaking your balls Paul cuz I know
you listening I know you listening
alright so there you go I almost went
500 for the year against the spread
which from what I've done but I've been
told is is is pretty goddamn decent so
yeah I'm patting myself on the back
anyways let's plow ahead here so I have
to get in trash for all you know talking
[ __ ] about all these corporations and
actually having the audacity to think
that bankers were all trying to team up
and have one World Bank you know to
become the loan sharks
for not only individual but actual
countries okay
which is something that I was thinking
about when I was at the Rose Bowl
stoned sober and I was sitting there on
the golf course and I was looking at
these houses up on up on the ridge of
this hill that actually looked down on
the Rose Bowl the granddaddy of them all
these people have a house that looks
down on it and I was actually
envisioning that those were all bankers
up there and while the game was going on
and a hundred and four thousand people
or ninety six thousand whoever showed up
for that game we're sitting there going
[ __ ] crazy one of those piece-of-shit
bankers up there could put his hand on
his son's shoulder and be like see all
those people down there they all of us
money they all owe me money son I'm
getting a piece of all of their [ __ ]
paychecks and they don't even know it
they don't even know that their daddy is
looking down on him right now now had I
been drinking that thought would have
probably caused me to you know entertain
the thought of climbing up that hill and
throwing a rock through one of the
windows which of course I wouldn't have
done because even my drunkest I am aware
that I don't want to go to jail and get
raped and secondly I I really up that
[ __ ] Hill so what I would have done
is I probably would have yelled at that
kid with the light purple slacks I would
have commented really loud about that
dudes [ __ ] eczema flaking off into
the back of his goddamn sweatshirt so
anyways this guy sends me this email and
he says I build the Vaes in this blog
when I say they are watching our big
business not the Illuminati but they are
just as evil as any bank or secret
society they don't even need your
signature listen to this [ __ ] they don't
even need your signature for these
information-gathering
traitor where programs to monitor
everything from where the device is to
what your heart rate is thanks for
giving me something to look forward to
on Mondays also I like your Christmas
tree you should turn it into a walking
stick now that the holidays are over
you guys are so dumb you guys are buying
shrubs do you realize that look out your
window and look at tree
you can see the trunk you dumb [ __ ]
it's like you know you give your morons
look at a shrub can you see that you
can't you're buying shrubs that are
pruned into the shape of Christmas tree
I had the information from an actual
[ __ ] guy last week all right
I bought a Christmas tree you brought a
Christmas shrub so go [ __ ] yourselves
but I like this guy cuz he sends me this
what is trader wear that's the question
I had
I'm your digital camera may embed
metadata into photographs with cameras
serial number or your location your
printer may be incorporating a secret
code on every page at prints which could
be used to identify the printer and
potentially the person who used it now
now the [ __ ] morons the sheep out
there be like yeah that's in case you
threatened the president they're just
doing it for the good of all people if
Apple puts a particularly creepy patent
I guess apples applying for this is it
recently applied for the use for you can
look forward to a day when your iPhone
may record your voice take a picture of
your location record your heartbeat and
send that information back to the
mothership this is Trey to where devices
that act behind your back and betray
your privacy now this is what the [ __ ]
sheep are going to be to say well if you
do nothing wrong
what's the problem that's that's the
philosophy that was the philosophy
behind why they can record your phone
calls now if you ain't doing nothing
what I see you come on frogs ain't doing
nothing wrong do you realize how [ __ ]
dumb that mindset is so basically as
long as you do what the people in power
tell you what to do you won't have a
problem do you understand how dangerous
that is do you understand how [ __ ]
stupid it is to have that level of faith
in the people who rule you you know what
I mean
you haven't noticed how much power can
[ __ ] somebody over like for some reason
we only seem to focus on when
celebrities get famous and then they wig
out and start becoming these [ __ ]
mini tyrants for some reason people
don't feel they just have like this
because they waved a flag and they they
and they play those songs that make you
choked up that they never feel like that
they'll have any sort of ulterior motive
for this this is the type of technology
that allows a small group of people to
take over the world
something that sociopaths have been
trying to do since the beginning of time
and they were never able to do it
because at some point your army would be
stretched too thin right the Germans the
[ __ ] Roman Empire all that [ __ ] at
some point the [ __ ] Japanese all of
them everybody who's ever tried to
[ __ ] do it at some point it gets
stretched too thin so America what we've
done is we've then we've we've done the
we're putting this base here to protect
you
thing that brilliant thing that's how we
got our world Empire so we just have a
base then also we have these insane
weapons where we can nuke everybody so
we were able to kind of do it that way
but the problem is is when you really
get into sociopathic thought and just
like those people who are so into power
that it makes their dick hard is they
want to know they want to be able to see
everybody know what they're thinking and
know what they're doing at all times
because not only they psychos but with
that level of power becomes this
unbelievable level of paranoia like
those people with those houses sitting
on the ridge looking down into the Rose
Bowl there's a fear like we sit there
looking up and go look at they got the
[ __ ] world there was a fear of when
you attain that level of wealth of
losing all of it and you begin on this
this quest to quiet your mind you want
you want to get a level of wealth and
control in your life that you are
guaranteed that it will never go away in
your lifetime or
your kid's lifetime or your kids kids so
basically everybody that you know and
love will be okay and you will be okay
you get into that psychotic [ __ ]
mindset and you give those kinds of
people
this level of [ __ ] technology and
you're gonna have a problem
I think that's unbelievable but that
this [ __ ] is and so they have this this
website here the e FF Electronic
Frontier Foundation that is trying to
fight these things being put into into
the detect you know the cameras the cell
phones and all that [ __ ] like the fact
that there's a tracking device in your
cell phone like how come we didn't get
to vote on that how come we don't get to
vote on that type of stuff I don't want
people knowing where the [ __ ] I am at
all goddamn times okay
and I don't need you to show me oh we
caught this [ __ ] child molester with
that so because of that now everybody
has to be like give me a [ __ ] break
they always have like you know that
there's you know a handful of good
examples for that level of [ __ ]
control and then there's a zillion bad
ones so I am 100% against this [ __ ] and
there's always been evil people in the
[ __ ] world there's always going to be
evil [ __ ] people in the world and
when you get when you have this kind of
technology that you're gonna you're
gonna stop they're gonna stop small evil
like individual you know a [ __ ]
serial rapist what you definitely want
to stop all right but the price we're
gonna pay is you're gonna allow a Stalin
or a Hitler Pol Pot whoever the [ __ ] you
wanted that you're gonna let the with
that level of technology up someone like
that could get in power and run the
[ __ ] world so you know I don't know
and I totally 100% believe that you
could roll all your [ __ ] eyes all you
want III honestly believe that and I
also believe that the reason why there's
so many of us right now and that the
people at the top are not [ __ ]
concerned about it is because we're all
expendable and when the waters rise up
the temperatures goes up and everything
they're not going to be the ones who are
drowning you can guarantee that they use
in our taxpayer
money to build some sort of something to
make sure that they're okay and I think
that their bailout plan because they
know they can't stop people from [ __ ]
because it feels too goddamn good and
dicks and [ __ ] are readily available
to anyone it's like air you know so I
think what they're gonna gradually do is
phase us out with robots an automated
[ __ ] which is why I refuse to use it now
how [ __ ] crazy do I sound right now
has there been anything funny in the
last [ __ ] five this is [ __ ] that I
truly believe you know corporations own
like the DNA of a grizzly bear that's
why they don't give a [ __ ] that they're
cutting down its habitat they're like I
will [ __ ] grow another one in a petri
dish we're trying to take over
everything and then wipe out I think
they're gonna try to wipe out the poor
in the middle class keep a couple of us
like a small handful of us you know the
way that pandas are only in like zoos at
this point or some [ __ ]
I don't know maybe I picked the wrong
[ __ ] animal but that that's that's
the direction I think it's going all
right
this your first crazy rant which was
based mainly and gut feelings in a
couple of emails but I truly believe
that and I browsed through enough enough
history hey Cleo
what's up